[Music]
tonal 66
is like a way for the mit community to
come together
we came up with this idea that would be
a really good representation
of the mit community and be able to
connect us all in isolation
it's just like a really long vertical
tunnel online virtual tunnel where
mit students and mit affiliates can just
draw their own
space and add it to a growing collection
of everyone's spaces so that it's like
we're all quarantining
together in the same tunnel the hope is
that you can like
draw either like a place on campus that
you've missed
or a place like your room on campus or
your current quarantine room
um and it's a way of like bringing all
that together to like
remember and connect with the community
in general borderline
um tries to give students at mit a space
um and place to like create
art a lot of the murals that we have um
are ar
enabled so if you put up your phone to
the mural you could see an animation
playing over it
and currently the animations have a
little um welcoming message to the 2024s
as a way to kind of bring them into the
the project
tunnel 66 led um us
like the students like the student body
see oh wait there's like this
artistic aspect of mit that
sometimes people don't think about as
much like the general
public's perception of mit is usually
like it's super technical
everyone's a hardcore math and science
nerds but i'm really
glad that there's an art community that
i hope to join
all of our rooms are connected by the
ladder and
it just feels like wow like although
we're all like a part in
all around the world our hearts are a
little bit of our heart is connected
by sharing this um whatever we're
thinking
or doing with everybody else and i like
to think that the mit community
has like one single beating heart i
would love to have people be able to go
on the site
and feel like they're a part of
something and
feel that one beating heart and i think
that that's the beautiful part
about it is that we're all so different
yet we all can come together
you